-♪ Dance battle, yeah ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This here
is the dance move generator.
We're going to take turns
hitting this button,
which will randomly select
a never-before-seen dance move.
And in honor of your movie
"The Perfect Date,"
all of our dances will be
high school related.
[ Cheering ]
And we'll be doing this
on the high school dance floor
over here.
Whoever's turn it is has to
make up a dance for that move,
and the best dancer wins.
All right. I will start us off
since I'm the host.
Let's start
the dance move generator.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Mm!
[ Whoosh! ]
"Science Room Lava Lamp."
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughs ]
-"Science Room Lava Lamp."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Wait a minute.
-One, two, three!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
I'm warming up, warming up.
I'm getting limber.
I'm getting limber. Right.
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah,
you'll definitely top that.
All right, you're up, Noah.
Let's start
the dance move generator.
Here we go.
[ Chiming ]
[ Whoosh! ]
"Dirty Dancing When
the Chaperone Ain't Looking."
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Dirty Dancing When
the Chaperone Ain't Looking."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Chuckles ]
Oh, that's good.
That's good enough.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-[ Laughs ]
All right. That was pretty good.
It's my turn again.
Let's start the generator.
[ Chiming ]
[ Whoosh! ]
The "All I Know
is Musical Theatre."
[ Laughter, cheering ]
All right. Give me a beat.
-One, two,
one, two, three, four.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoo!
-[ Whistling ]
-You're -- You're up, Noah.
-[ Laughs ]
-Let's see what you got.
Let's start the generator.
[ Chiming ]
-Jazz hands.
[ Whoosh! ]
[ Laughter ]
-Dude, you already got
a head start on that one.
"Is This How
You're Supposed to Grind?"
So you're a -- You're a man who
does not know how to grind.
-Okay, yeah.
-One, two, three, four.
♪♪
[ Cheering ]
-Whoa, whoa. Hey. Whoa, whoa.
All right. Hey, good.
That's good. It's good.
-Okay.
♪♪
[ Indistinct ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Gosh.
-[ Laughs ]
I think that's how you do it.
-We made your mom
leave the room for that.
-All right.
[ Laughter ]
-You know, you're clearly
the better dance.
Why even compete
against each other
when we can do one more dance
together?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Dance move generator!
[ Chiming ]
Ready?
-Set.
-Go.
[ Whoosh! ]
"Making Eye Contact
with Everyone
but the Person
You're Slow-Dancing With."
[ Laughter, cheering ]
[ Chuckles ]
♪ Getting to know you ♪
[ Laughs ]
All right.
You going right now?
-Should I?
-I don't know.
If I go waist...
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Indistinct ]
-[ Laughs ]
Noah Centineo right there!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for having
a "Tonight Show" dance battle,
buddy, we love you.